[Musique]
mesdames Messieurs chers amis
comme il est de traditions ce mois de
janvier permettez-moi tout d'abord de
vous adresser mes meilleurs vœux de
bonheur et de santé et d'épanouissement
pour cette nouvelle année j'espère que
vous abordez 2023 ces moments de fête
qui permettent de se retrouver entre
amis ou en famille ces moments qui
revêtent une importance singulière dans
le contexte difficile que nous
traversons
alors que la crise sanitaire nous avait
déjà éprouvé la guerre en Ukraine les
tensions géopolitiques importantes
conjuguées à la maintenance des
centrales nucléaires ont provoqué une
crise énergétique majeure elle s'est
traduite par une augmentation massive du
prix de l'électricité et du gaz et une
forte inflation sur tous les produits
nous savions bien que la hausse du coût
de la vie a des conséquences importantes
pour de nombreuses familles généraux FN
c'est vrai pour payer le loyer pour
faire les courses pour payer le Pass
Navigo ou encore le plein d'essence pour
accéder aux loisirs au sport à la
culture
cette situation nous oblige à être
encore plus vigilant et actif sur les
dispositifs de solidarité locale pour
faire face ensemble et soutenir les plus
fragiles d'entre nous
côté de nos partenaires nous savons
qu'il nous faudra faire face pour ne
laisser personne sur le bord du chemin
et la période difficile que nous
traversons ne doit pas avoir pour
réponse le repli l'égoïsme l'abandon ou
la résignation c'est face aux épreuves
que nous devons relever le meilleur de
nous-mêmes nous devons faire vivre de la
façon la plus concrète possible les
valeurs de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité ces valeurs qui sont au cœur
de notre République au cœur de
l'engagement de notre ville et pour
faire face ensemble il nous faut
défendre bec et ongles les services
publics de proximité ces services
essentiels sans lesquels tant de
familles se retrouveront en difficulté
les services publics qui sont
aujourd'hui clairement menacés dans de
nombreuses villes et de nombreux
villages de France tant les communes
sont aujourd'hui exemples financièrement
en effet les villes comme les agglo ne
bénéficient pas de l'aide de l'État à la
hauteur des besoins énergétiques
vertigineux que nous connaissons et le
bouclier tarifaire qui limite la hausse
du prix des énergies à 15% pour les
particuliers ne s'appliquent pas aux
collectivités à Sainte-Geneviève par
exemple nous avons appris il y a
quelques semaines que le prix de
l'électricité pour être pratiquement
multiplié par 4 en une seule année très
concrètement cela représenterait 2,2
millions d'euros en 2023 contre 600 000
euros en 2022 pour payer la facture
d'électricité de la ville face à ces
hausses vertigineuses certaines mairies
ont décidé de vendre ou de fermer
définitivement des piscines des gymnases
et parfois même des écoles
ici dans notre ville nous avons fait un
autre choix celui de porter un plan de
sobriété ambitieux qui permet de
maintenir tous nos équipements publics
couverts c'est un choix que nous
assumons c'est vrai que certaines
décisions difficiles ont déjà dû être
prises c'est le cas par exemple de notre
marché de Noël c'est le cas également de
la traditionnelle soirée des vœux du
maire et de la municipalité ou encore
des traditionnelles illuminations de
Noël mais bien qu'elle n'ait pas été
prise de gaieté de cœur ces décisions
étaient indispensables
d'autres ont été prises depuis dans le
cadre de la préparation du budget 2023
chacune d'entre elles permet à notre
ville de poursuivre ses missions
essentielles et de garder tous nos
équipements publics couverts c'est le
parti que nous avons choisi celui de
l'action face à celui de la résignation
mais nous savons aussi que jamais notre
ville n'aurait été confronté à de telles
difficultés tant aujourd'hui le prix de
l'électricité du gaz sont fixées par
l'inflation et la spéculation face à la
crise énergétique nous avons décidé de
réorienter nos investissements pour
accélérer la transition écologique
énergétique ainsi la rénovation
thermique de nos gymnases poursuit et à
Romain Rolland le chantier s'achèvera au
cours du printemps dans le même temps
nous accélérons le changement des
éclairages des bâtiments municipaux pour
passer au LED bien moins énergivores et
donc source d'importantes économies un
plan de changement des éclairages qui
adore c'est déjà commencer en la fin de
l'année 2002 ces investissements sont
nécessaires ils le sont autant pour
préserver notre environnement que pour
réaliser des économies importantes dans
la période que nous vivons
mais la mobilisation de la ville ne
s'arrête pas là l'envoler des prix des
énergies vient autant de la guerre et
des difficultés d'approvisionnement que
de la dérégulation et du fonctionnement
du marché européen qui fixent les prix
de l'énergie se battre pour le service
public de l'énergie et se battent pour
la régulation des prix est une nécessité
absolue notre ville s'engagera
pleinement dans cette bataille dans
l'issue est déterminante tant pour
chacun d'entre nous que pour toutes nos
communes
mais je ne terminerai pas ses vœux sur
une note pessimiste qui viendrait à
oublier ou à minimiser tous les projets
que la ville a supporté malgré les
conditions difficiles que j'ai évoquées
l'année 2022 qui s'est achevée a été
riche pour Sainte-Geneviève pour son
environnement et pour son attractivité
aussi et je ne citerai que quelques
réalisations parmi beaucoup d'autres
pour illustrer les travaux de la gare
d'abord qui visent à la rendre
accessible pour tous ils ont débuté en
2022 et c'est poursuivront en 2023 la
rénovation thermique et l'extension du
Gymnase Romain Rolland être bien avancé
et permettra nos sportifs et à nos
scolaires de bénéficier des meilleures
conditions possibles pour pratiquer leur
activité ensuite le réseau de chaleur
issu de la géothermie il a commencé à
fonctionner en octobre après de longs
mois de travaux menés avec beaucoup de
professionnalisme
même si aujourd'hui encore le travail
avec certains bailleurs doit être
poursuivi afin d'améliorer le confort de
certains locataires
la géothermie permet d'ores et déjà
à plusieurs milliers de genovés fin mais
également la ville d'accéder à une
énergie dont le prix est stable dans le
temps et très peu polluant
et vous l'avez vu au cours de l'été
dernier la place du marché du donjon
c'est totalement transformée avec un
important programme de
désinterméabilisation et de
végétalisation qui a permis d'en faire
un exemple de transition écologique et
de résilience environnementale
l'opération adopte un arbre qui a permis
en associant tous les Génos fins de
planter plus de 3000 arbres
supplémentaires dans la ville en
seulement quelques mois 3000 arbres pour
lutter contre les îlots de chaleur pour
réduire notre empreinte carbone et pour
embellir Sainte-Geneviève d'ailleurs sur
ce point notre ville vient de se voir
confirmer sa quatrième fleur et obtenue
un prix national pour la reconquête
écologique de son cadre urbain en étant
la seule ville de France à obtenir cette
distinction
la médiathèque Olivier Léonard tentatonu
à enfin ouvert ses portes officiellement
le 1er octobre faisant d'elle le faire
de lance de la culture pour tous en
plein cœur du quartier des honnêtes à
quelques pas du lycée cet équipement
extraordinaire fait la fierté de notre
ville et de l'agglomération qui l'a
financé et des habitants jeunes et moins
jeunes qui s'y rendent toujours plus
nombreux elle a pris le nom de notre
ancien maire et a mis Olivier Léonard
afin de saluer son engagement sans
faille pour notre ville et pour
l'ensemble du territoire de cœur des
hommes
enfin pour nos enfants et pour nos
jeunes la ville a obtenu le label cité
éducatif qui a permis d'obtenir des
moyens financiers et humains
supplémentaires nécessaires pour les
accompagner vers l'épanouissement et la
réussite
ce ne sont que quelques exemples parmi
toutes les actions conduites l'an passé
et dont certaines se poursuivront en
2023 mais elle signe bien le fait que
malgré la crise notre ville continue de
se moderniser de s'embellir et de se
préparer pour les défis à venir
mais tous ces projets ont la même
particularité faire vivre et développer
l'action publique de proximité en étant
très largement co-financé par nos
partenaires ou payer intégralement par
eux comme c'est le cas pour la gare ou
la médiathèque à titre je tiens à
remercier nos partenaires mais également
les élus du conseil municipal qui
m'accompagnent et l'ensemble des agents
de la ville pour le formidable travail
qu'ils accomplissent au quotidien sans
eux tous ces projets ne pourraient pas
voir le jour et le service public
municipal ne pourrait pas être aussi
performant
profite également de ces quelques mots
pour remercier très chaleureusement
toutes celles et tous ceux qui œuvrent
chaque jour
à nos côtés en direction de l'ensemble
des géno FN et des génovins comme en
témoignent l'engagement des agents des
services publics des agences des
services publics de l'État de l'hôpital
de la sécurité encore ceux de
l'éducation nationale je voudrais
également remercier les milliers de
bénévoles associatifs qui œuvrent sans
compter pour donner un autre ville le
dynamisme que nous lui connaissons
mesdames et messieurs je conclurai
simplement en disant que j'amène notre
ville ne renoncera à faire ce qui fait
son identité et son âme avec une
attention toute particulière à notre
cadre de vie d'abord la solidarité
exprimée envers les plus fragiles
ensuite et une ambition forte tant en
matière d'attractivité de dynamisme
commercial ou de transition écologique
en fin
mais surtout avec la ferme intention de
continuer quelle que soit les
circonstances et peut-être plus encore
avec celle que nous vivons aujourd'hui à
faire ensemble Sainte-Geneviève avec
chacune et chacun d'entre vous
je crois viscéralement dans la force et
les ressources de notre ville et je suis
certain que nous arriverons à faire face
ensemble
une nouvelle fois au nom du Conseil
Municipal je vous présente mes meilleurs
vœux pour cette nouvelle année puis
cette nouvelle année nous donner la
force collective de faire face ensemble
pour vivre mieux
[Musique]